there are movie stars and then there was
Burt Reynolds Hollywood lost one of the
all-time greats today you know women
love them guys wanted to be him and he
kept working right up until the very end
there will never be another Burt
Reynolds
I don't have a lot of regrets I did the
best I could and I had a good time
wonderful time
the 82 year old Hollywood legend
reportedly went into cardiac arrest this
morning at a Florida Hospital in a
statement his family said quote he has
had health issues however this was
totally unexpected and et has obtained
the 911 call made from Bert's estate at
12:47 p.m. today
Bert looked frail during his last et
interview it was in March at the
premiere of his film the last movie star
are you proud though of your career
you've got a beer well I am yes I was
number one in the world for five years
in a row that was Bert's last public
appearance was in April at the Palm
Beach International Film Festival and it
turns out his last movie project was
supposed to be a big one he had signed
on to Quinton Tarantino's film Once Upon
a Time in Hollywood with Brad Pitt and
Leonardo DiCaprio that is Burt headed
into a table reading in June but he had
yet to shoot his scene Burt was a fox of
his legend whose easygoing style made
him one of the biggest stars of the
1970s and 80s from Smokey and the Bandit
to The Longest Yard and deliverance Burt
showed how he could swing from comedy to
series drama sometimes you have to lose
yourself before you find anything
I have a habit of making when I do look
very easy considered a sex symbol in
1972 he famously posed naked on a
bearskin rug for Cosmopolitan magazine
it's frightening to think that I had do
that people tell me I have a real sexy
quality about me college football star
in the movies I often did his own stunts
which resulted in injuries and living
with pain he also battled series
illnesses I went in to have a checkup
and they said you've got a clogged
artery and then had a back operation
I've always felt lucky in my life I had
an incredible life I've been so blessed
I know it's because you have a couple
close calls and it makes you start
grabbing at life a little harder his one
and only Oscar nomination came from
Boogie Nights he puts up all the money
for our films it's an important part of
process he played a director of adult
films who mentors a young Mark Wahlberg
this afternoon Wahlberg paid tribute
posting this photo from the sent robin
williams wound up winning the Oscar for
Good Will Hunting but Burt did win a
Golden Globe for the role in 1998 things
I come back and I go away Burt Reynolds
was a good friend to all of us at et
from the very beginning in fact he
appeared on our very first broadcast
back in 1981 and even then he spoke
about his own mortality and if there was
the life hereafter and I think there is
that
the hell's all the fuss about it's just
that I don't want to go now
[Music]
you